57 years since martin luther king had a
dream
delivered on these steps america is
still
fighting to fulfill it his granddaughter
at the forefront
we are going to be the generation that
cause a halt to police brutality and gun
violence once and for all
now and forever the shooting of jacob
blake by a white police officer
has only added fuel to their fire his
father
now a central voice in the fight there
are two
systems of justice in the united states
there's a white system and there's a
black system
the black system ain't doing so well
but we're going to stand up every black
person in the united states is going to
stand up
we're tired i'm tired
they want equality something that's
remained elusive
we treated with disrespect by policemen
that we pay their salaries like we don't
matter
so we figured we let you know whether we
tall or sharp
fat or skinny light skinned the dark
skin
black lives matter many black people in
this country feel
under threat and undervalued black
people
black excellence and minds have
contributed so much to america we will
not be
america without black people how
concerned are you
by the violence and the unrest you see
on the street
that's when people listen it's when
their businesses are affected
that's when they listen when their money
is affected so if we have to
shut stuff down then that's what we're
gonna have to
[Applause]
from the do memorial they marched to the
feet of the man who inspired
generations this is a galvanizing moment
for people but it's also a deeply
painful one and it's hard to see
any relief for that pain without major
change
not only in american hearts and minds
but critically
in institutions but there is a president
pushing
another agenda law and order the
republican party condemns the rioting
looting arson and violence we have seen
in democrat-run cities all
like kenosha minneapolis portland
chicago and new york
it feels like america is two separate
universes right now
it must decide which one it wants and if
there's any hope of helping build it
together